-Thank you so much
for having me.
I appreciate it so much.
-We love you, buddy.
-Jimmy, as a magician, I believe
that nothing is random,
that every decision that
we make is based on
some decision
that was made previously,
from this moment, all the way
back to when you were born.
-Okay.
-Jimmy, I've had people in
the audience write down
four-digit numbers
on these cards.
Four random -- Do you guys
remember doing that?
Four-random-digit numbers
on these cards.
-Oh, really?
-Alright, in a second,
I'm gonna have some of The Roots
choose some
of these numbers, alright?
So, we're gonna start
over here with Mark.
If you wouldn't mind, please
just touch one.
Any one. Take it out.
Don't show anybody else.
Look at it, remember it.
Try to remember it and stand up.
-Dan, don't forget about me.
What do I do?
-Just touch one.
-Do I not look at you?
-Take it out, look at it,
stand up, remember it.
Great. Quest,
if you wouldn't mind,
just touch the back of one.
-Am I dead?
-Good. Take it out, look at it,
remember it, stand up,
hold it against your chest.
And, finally, Tariq, if you
wouldn't mind, just touch one.
-What's happening?
This is so weird.
-Good, take it out,
look at it, remember it,
hold it against your chest.
Alright.
-Did you hear me at all
when I was --
-I didn't hear anything at all.
-I was yelling at you.
-What did you say?
-Was I supposed to look?
-No, I don't want you to look.
-Well, it's too late now.
I didn't --
-The numbers --
you guys remember the numbers?
Commit them to memory.
Great. Perfect. Great.
This is where
your part comes in.
-Okay.
-We're going to create
another random number,
but this random number, we're
gonna use the audience for.
I've got a ball here,
a paper ball.
I want you to throw that ball
out into the audience,
anywhere you want
at all, Jimmy, anywhere.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Perfect. Great.
Miss, how are you doing?
I want you to think of a
number between 10 and 20.
Between 10 and up to 20.
Say it now.
-13.
Jimmy, can you please take
one of those markers,
and I want you to write "13" on
those two first slots
right there.
-Okay.
-1, 3.
Great. Take that ball, throw it
somewhere else in the room,
anywhere you like.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great.
Sir, different question
this time, actually.
I want you to think of
a number between 1 and 9.
Say it now.
-6.
-Six. Jimmy, can you please
write down "6"?
Fantastic. Sir, take that ball,
throw it anywhere you want.
Good, hard toss.
Very good.
Sir, same question --
number between 1 and 9.
Say it out loud.
-5.
-5. Write down "5."
Very good.
And one more toss.
Just throw it wherever you want.
Great, perfect.
Same question.
Give me a number between
1 and 9, please, now.
-3.
Write down "3."
Very, very good.
Perfect. Great.
Okay, so, you can cap that pen.
Let's just recap, right?
We took a whole bunch of numbers
that the audience wrote down.
The Roots then
chose four random numbers
from those random numbers.
Then we threw out a ball,
making five random numbers.
-Yes.
-1-3-6-5-3.
13,653.
Did that feel random to you?
-Yes.
-That felt pretty random, right?
I mean, there's no way
I could have known
what numbers that
they would have said.
There's no way
I could have known
the numbers they wrote down.
-Very seriously, I don't talk to
you before the show.
I just whipped
that ball out there.
I didn't know who it was.
-But that's the thing.
Even if I had known,
I could have no idea
who would have
gotten those numbers, right?
-Yes, random.
-Here's the interesting part.
I've had a box sitting here
the entire time.
It's been sitting there
I haven't touched it.
Inside of this box,
I brought two things.
Two things for you.
The first thing is a present.
I'm going to give this
to you right now.
Hold on to that.
-Thank you.
-Great. The second thing is
a prediction of sorts.
I've wrote down something before
the show even started.
Can you make sure that that
envelope is sealed?
-Yes.
-Sealed.
Can you make sure that
this envelope is sealed?
-Yes, it is.
-Great.
Jimmy, can you please open up
the prediction.
Jimmy,
would you be impressed if,
inside of that envelope --
open it up --
inside of that envelope
was the number
that they all
created together?
-Yes, I would be impressed.
Of course.
-It's not. It's not, right?
It's not. It's not.
It's actually much more
impressive than that.
On this piece of paper,
I have four random numbers.
Four random numbers.
Now, at the beginning,
we had four random numbers
chosen by The Roots.
-That's right.
-Mark, Kirk, Quest, Tariq.
If your number is written on
this piece of paper,
I'd like you to sit down now.
-What?
-Interesting.
But it gets a lot more
interesting than that,
because here is the crazy part.
If we take 8 plus 3 is 11,
plus 2, is 13.
Carry the 1.
1 plus 1 plus 4
plus 4 plus 5 is 15.
Carry the 1.
1 plus 2 plus 2
plus 5 plus 6 is 16.
Carry the 1.
1 plus 1 plus 7 plus 2 is 13.
1-3-6-5-3.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How? How did you do that?
Amazing!
That's Dan White.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But we're not done.
We're not done.
Because this isn't actually as
random as this is going to get,
because we threw out
a ball earlier.
That ball went around the room
a bunch of different times.
Who was the last person
to catch that ball?
Alright, great.
Can you please stand up?
Can you please unfold that ball?
On that ball, I wrote something
before the show even started.
Can you please read --
Jimmy, can you please read out
what that piece of paper says?
-It says, "Subtract 2,444."
-Subtract 2,444.
Subtract 2,444.
Now, again, remember,
at the beginning,
we created this number together.
Before that,
I wrote down this number.
Check this out.
If we take -- That is 9.
Zero.
-I'm so happy
I don't have to do this.
-Yeah, right?
2, 1, 1.
11,209.
-Yeah.
-11,209.
-Yes. Okay.
-We did it.
-Okay.
-Yeah. We did it this time.
-We did it.
-We really did it this time.
11,000. I get it.
-Does that feel random?
-Yeah, it feels --
-That feels random.
That feels really random.
-Feels about right.
-Jimmy, does this number mean
anything to you, 11,209?
Jimmy, can you please
pull out your phone?
open it up?
And I want you to Google
the number 1-1-2-0-9.
Please Google the number
1-1-2-0-9.
And, at the very beginning,
I mentioned
that I don't believe
in randomness,
that all the decisions are made
based on other decisions
that were made
since you were born.
Jimmy, what is 11209?
It's a zip code, yeah?
-It's a -- Yeah.
-A zip code to where?
-Brooklyn, New York.
-Where in Brooklyn, New York?
-This is Bay Ridge.
-Bay Ridge.
Can you please tell everyone
here why 11209
is not random at all?
-I was born in Bay Ridge,
Brooklyn.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And just as a souvenir,
I got you a little...
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh!
You are unbelievable!
Dan White! Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was awesome!
For tickets to "The Magician,"
visit nomadupstairs.com.